[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission pour bien démarrer la
soirée dans les Yvelines avec au
programme de l'actualité des infos
pratiques et des idées de sortie voici
le programme de ce lundi 14 novembre
jusqu'au 20 novembre c'est la deuxième
semaine de sensibilisation au 100 rares
seulement quatre personnes sur 1000 sont
concernées en France mais
l'établissement français du sang a
besoin de donneur pour soigner les
malades stefanoël directeur de l'efsi de
France c'est notre invité
j-6 avant le début de la Coupe du monde
de football depuis aujourd'hui l'équipe
de France se prépare au Centre national
de Clairefontaine en Yvelines avant de
s'envoler pour le Qatar ce sera mercredi
nous vous emmenons dans les coulisses de
ce camp de base au combien important
pour les Bleus et puis comme tous les
lundis notre page consacrée aux
résultats sport du week-end retour
notamment sur Parcourir Montigny environ
1000 participants au prix le départ
dimanche de cette course qui traversait
Montigny-le-Bretonneux nous reviendrons
aussi sur l'abandon de livinois Louis
Burton sur la Route du Rhum après un
énième dématage
focus également tout à l'heure sur le
poste de gardien de but un poste au
combien important et je parle en
connaissance de cause vous en saurez
plus tout à l'heure Michel et nidoro est
également avec moi en plateau de la
rédaction de TV 78 bonsoir Mickaël avec
vous les résultats sports du week-end à
suivre et on parle avec votre invité en
invité également sport mais invité
emploi dans cette édition
digitale qui sert au recrutement pour
les sportifs c'est bien ça bike c'est
exactement ça donc ce sera un plaisir
d'en parler avec tout le monde en tout
cas merci merci d'être avec nous Mike on
revient également sur ce rendez-vous qui
s'est tenu à Chatou c'est une journée
nationale de la protection adaptée elle
a été organisée par le groupe arpaville
l'agence interdépartementale de
l'autonomie vinots de scène et la
société Noé son président est avec nous
en plateau bon sortie rideau Noé
professionnel de santé c'est donc le nom
de cette société quel était les
objectifs de cette journée puis de 5
millions de personnes en France portent
des protections 92% d'entre elles
portent des protections inadaptées non
pas de solution il faut les informer et
donc on parlera tout à l'heure de cet
enjeu de santé publique mais aussi un
enjeu d'intérêt public on le verra tout
à l'heure à suivre également avec vous
réginera Liège bonsoir de la rédaction
TV 78 les informations du jour on parle
de quoi ce soir
mais je peux d'ores et déjà vous dire
qu'on parlera de l'arrivée des Bleus à
Clairefontaine mais également d'info
pratique que la baisse de la ristourne
sur les carburants qui arrivent à grands
pas une mauvaise nouvelle qui va arriver
ce sera mercredi on aura l'occasion d'en
parler avec vous dans un instant et ce
sera juste après la météo du jour
et même la météo de demain avec une
journée plutôt morose qui s'annonce
mardi dans les Yvelines de la grisaille
le matin il fera 9 degrés à Rambouillet
10 degrés à Versailles ou dans et
Mantes-la-Jolie il devrait même pleuvoir
dans l'après-midi compter 12 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et Houdan ce
sera légèrement plus frais dans le sud
des Yvelines à Rambouillet où il fera 11
degrés ce mardi et à 15 novembre ce sera
la saint Albert mais nous fêterons aussi
les albertes Albertine et également les
Arthur
les informations du jour à présent avec
vous Régine raleche et on le débute on
le disait qu'une mauvaise nouvelle qui
va arriver mercredi c'est la réduction
sur la riston des carburants alors oui
donc mercredi 16 novembre la remise
carburant du gouvernement passera de 30
centimes à 10 centimes et celle de Total
passeront de 20 centimes à 10 centimes
par litre d'essence alors ce qui amène
beaucoup d'entre vous à se déplacer vers
les stations d'essence avec beaucoup de
précipitations alors je Patrick Jacques
de Dixmude s'est rendu dans une station
essence à Voisins-le-Bretonneux on
écoute les témoignages en fin de compte
je pense que au bout d'un moment faut
bien que ça s'arrête parce que du coup
en fin de compte ça va coûter cher à
l'ensemble par contre faudrait peut-être
cibler l'aide en effet il faut trop que
sous sur l'essence et on est trop taxé
là les Français ils en peuvent plus
et toujours point de vue circulation la
limitation à 30 km/h dans la ville de
Triel-sur-Seine c'est terminé Cédric
aoum Le Maire de la ville à formalisé sa
décision au moyen d'un arrêté la
décision la raison pardon des
comportements dangereux et accidentaux
gènes auraient selon lui été constaté
sur des axes désormais la limitation à
30 km/h c'est limitera au centre-ville
et les grands axes de circulation
repasseront progressivement à 30 km
heure à 50 km/h
qui était passé au 30 km/h et qui
reviennent sur cette décision alors pour
les fans du football c'est l'image du
jour Régine avec un événement qui se
rapproche la Coupe du monde de football
beaucoup de fans sont impatients et
aujourd'hui les Bleus sont arrivés à
Clairefontaine pour préparer cet
échéance effectivement à moins d'une
semaine du coup d'envoi du Mondial
qatari les Bleus sont bien arrivés à
Clairefontaine aujourd'hui pour leur
première assemblement c'est un stage de
deux jours qui est prévu et qui les
attend avant leur départ pour mercredi
il y a aussi des visites médicales et on
a d'ailleurs appris plutôt dans la
journée que le Monégasque Axel dit Zazie
remplacera le joueur presnel kimpembe
qui s'est blessé aux tendon d'Achille
au poste de défenseur et il rejoint lui
aussi une longue liste de blessés
d'absents de forfait pour ce Mondial qui
commence dimanche avec le match
d'ouverture qui est à Équateur la France
jouera mardi prochain face à l'Australie
après l'image du jour le chiffre du jour
effectivement donc les chiffres de jour
c'est 8,4% parce que 8,4% c'est le
pourcentage des demandeurs d'emploi en
situation de handicap en France et on en
parle parce que aujourd'hui justement
démarre la semaine européenne pour
l'emploi des personnes handicapées
l'objectif c'est de sensibiliser les
recruteurs et de faciliter l'accès à
l'emploi et nous recevrons d'ailleurs
demain dams l'entreprise dames c'est la
fondation faciline qui sont très axées
sur la question ils seront là pour nous
en parler
et on termine par le Paris fermier de
Rambouillet qui s'est tenu le week-end
dernier un marché historique qui
rassemble chaque année plus d'une
centaine d'agriculteurs et de vignerons
alors au programme dégustation de vin de
Champagne et de plats cuisiniers les
visiteurs sont ravis par l'événement on
écoute les interviews collectés par
Julien Leroy ça existe depuis un peu
près 27 ans on a commencé par des
marchés sur Paris aujourd'hui on est à
Rambouillet ça va faire bientôt 25 ans
qu'on fait ce qu'on fait ce salon sur
sur la Bergerie nationale on est en
général entre 100 et 130 producteurs
sur deux événements un au mois de mai et
un au mois de novembre c'est un petit
peu le style de vin que j'apprécie en
particulier un vin qui ressemble un
petit peu à des vins du Sud-Ouest que
j'aime bien et donc oui ça m'a plu ça
m'a plu surtout surtout le rouge je suis
très content d'avoir goûter un fromage
qui vient d'ici là où j'ai grandi donc
voilà un fromage de terroir très bon
on a pu à l'occasion de cet événement
également interviewé des producteurs
originaires des Yvelines on aura
l'occasion de vous présenter leurs
produits cette semaine dans les
différentes éditions du 7 8 merci Régine
rallès pour toutes ces informations et
si vous aussi près de chez vous vous
êtes témoin d'une information et d'un
fait qui vous fait réagir n'hésitez pas
à le dire sur nos réseaux en utilisant
le hashtag 7 8 news
mais dans l'actualité également les
commémorations des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 7 ans après l'effet des
cérémonies se sont déroulées ce dimanche
à Paris et à Saint-Denis il s'agissait à
des premières cérémonies depuis le
procès sur les attentats ses attentats
qui ont fait on le rappelle 131 morts et
413 blessés il y a un an nous avions
rencontré Thibault un yvelinois rescapé
avec sa femme de l'attaque du Bataclan
il revenait sur cette soirée du 13
novembre 2015 regardez il y a eu les
fameux bruits de pétard que beaucoup de
personnes ont rapporté et donc je me
suis attrapé mon épouse et nous sommes
allongés par terre
un moment j'ai relevé la tête pour et là
la salle était allumée et j'ai vu au
niveau du bar un homme un jeune homme
qui tirait sur les personnes qui étaient
au sol et c'est là que j'ai compris que
ben si on restait là on a les sans doute
on allait se faire tuer c'était certain
et si on essaie de partir ben peut-être
qu'on allait recevoir une balle mais au
moins on aurait essayé peut-être qu'on
aurait aussi la chance de sortir de là à
chaque fois qu'on entre une détonation
d'une arme ou une rafale on se disait
que la prochaine est peut-être pour nous
le Red nous prépare nous organise pour
sortir et quitter quitter le Bataclan en
envoyant le moins possible
qui est voilà on sort en file indienne
en regardant par terre
mais la vision périphérique vous voyez
fait qu'on capte quand même des
informations et c'est du chaos
absolument le cas oui total il y a du
sang absolument partout il y a des
éclats de balles il y a
c'est tout est cassé c'est tout est
dévasté c'est le décor absolument
partout on passera jamais à autre chose
c'est déjà par respect pour pour les
personnes qui ne sont pas sortis de
l'art parce qu'il y a une culpabilité
très très forte nous on a eu la chance
de sortir de là sans être blessé sans
perdre un proche mais il y a quand même
90 personnes qui sont mortes
au Bataclan
ce chiffre 4 personnes sur 1000 ont en
France un sang rare cela concerne peu de
monde mais le sang de ces personnes peut
être précieux pour soigner les malades
l'Établissement français du sang
organise sa deuxième semaine de
sensibilisation à cette thématique c'est
jusqu'à dimanche et pour en parler à un
invité nous a rejoint en plateau c'est
Stéphane Noël bonsoir bonsoir directeur
de l'établissement français
d'Île-de-France on a en profitera avec
vous pour faire aussi l'état des lieux
des stocks de produits sanguins en
Île-de-France déjà un élément de
définition qu'est-ce qu'on appelle un
sans rare écoutez on connaît tous les
groupes sanguins à Bo ça nous parle tous
le haut négatif le O positif etc mais il
faut savoir qu'il y A 380 systèmes de
groupe sanguin et dans la population et
en particulier les personnes originaires
des continents africains
de la plaque à froid antillaise sont
tout à fait concernés par ces 100 rares
ce sont des personnes qui portent un
sang qui est beaucoup plus rare que la
normale et de fait nous avons absolument
besoin de voir ces personnes venir à
nous pour donner leur sang tout
simplement parce que quand fait une
prise en charge transfusionnelle c'est
un peu comme dans le cas d'une greffe il
faut s'assurer de la plus grande
compatibilité possible entre le produit
sanguin que l'on va délivrer au patients
et le patient et ces produits sanguins
pour certains patients et bien nous ne
pouvons les trouver que dans cette
communauté affrontière pour pouvoir
prendre en charge des patients qui sont
eux-mêmes issus de cette communauté je
prends un exemple beaucoup des
affrontement antillais sont atteints
d'une maladie qui s'appelle la
drépanocytose la principale maladie
génétique au monde cette maladie pour la
prendre en charge certains patients ont
besoin régulièrement de renouveler leur
masse sanguine et à chaque fois qu'un
patient doit être pris en charge ce sont
plusieurs culot globulaires plusieurs
concentrés de globules rouges que nous
devons leur délivrer et nous ne savons
absolument besoin de trouver des
produits compatibles avec ces patients
et donc c'est sans rares concerne 700
000 personnes en France vous l'avez dit
toute l'importance d'organiser cette
semaine si vous faites un retour
d'expérience sur la première semaine
est-ce que ça avait amener justement des
gens à donner leur sang ces personnes
qui ont qui ont un sens rare alors oui
nous savons constater un léger
frémissement mais par rapport à cet
enjeu de santé publique on est vraiment
sur un enjeu de santé publique tout à
fait important aujourd'hui c'est pas
assez il nous en appelons véritablement
à l'ensemble de la population
francilienne à venir donner son sang
mais par qui régulièrement à ses
communautés parce que on espère tout ce
que ces donneurs qui viennent vers nous
n'auront jamais besoin d'une prise en
charge transfusionnelle en revanche il y
a des patients qui ont besoin d'eux ils
ont besoin de l'aide des membres de leur
communauté pour permettre leur prise en
charge et qu'elle soit réalisée la plus
convenablement possible donc venez à
nous et vous lisiez beaucoup de
difficultés à trouver des donneurs
peut-être parce qu'ils ignorent tout
simplement c'est qu'ils ont un son rare
est-ce que c'est possible aussi alors
tout à fait quand on porte un standard
on ne le sait pas à l'origine on ne le
sait pas le seul moyen de le savoir est
de venir à nous et lorsque nous aurons
un bonheur et bien nous pourrons sur la
base de d'éléments de questionnement qui
seront pratiqués par nos personnels
savoir s'il est souhaitable ou non
d'aller plus loin dans les analyses que
nous procéderons pour identifier si ce
donneur tout nom porteur d'un soir donc
un donneur ne peut pas savoir si les
porteurs sont rares c'est nous qui le
déciderons qui le définiront au regard
des caractéristiques du donneur qui se
présentera et qu'est-ce qui est au
programme de cette semaine quels sont
les actions justement déployées pour
pour cette semaine de sensibilisation
alors la première action est une venue
la plus importante possible des donneurs
de la communauté à frontières que vous
soyez né dans cette dans ces contrées ou
que vous ayez des ancêtres dans ces
contrées venez nous voir et ensuite nous
avons des actions de sensibilisation sur
nos collectes dans nos maisons du don et
puis nous avons une une action qui est
menée en lien avec l'université Paris
pour sensibiliser les étudiants de cette
université à cet enjeu et donc
difficulté vous le disiez à collecter ce
sont rares dans un contexte aussi on
imagine toujours tendu sur les stocks de
produits sanguins quel est l'état des
stocks aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on est dans
une situation encore délicate
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation qui est très délicate deux
chiffres ce matin
l'état des lieux au niveau national
était de 80000 vous concentrer de
globules rouges là il nous en faudrait
100 000 pour pouvoir assurer une prise
en charge tout à fait correcte de
l'ensemble des patients cette situation
de tension est le résulte de plusieurs
événements nous avons connu la pénurie
de carburant dans la région qui a
beaucoup marqué qui a fait que les
Franciliens se sont moins déplacés en le
voyait sur le périphérique parisien
beaucoup moins de véhicules
récemment la grève RATP a conduit
également à d'un seul coup à ce que la
fréquentation de nos lieux de collecte
baisse en particulier sur nos maisons du
don et nous avons besoin aujourd'hui de
la mobilisation de tous pour nous
permettre de restaurer les stocks et
pouvoir faire en sorte que nous
puissions prendre en charge
convenablement l'ensemble des patients
on imagine que ça n'aide pas il y a une
autre problématique en ce moment c'est
un manque de personnel il y a des
difficultés de recrutement aussi pour le
FS tout à fait des grandes difficultés
de recrutement pour l'établissement
français du sang comme pour l'ensemble
du secteur médico-social et ça n'aide
pas à peu près 10% de nos personnels de
nos collègues aujourd'hui manque dans
les effectifs et donc c'est à peu près
10% de collecteurs moins et c'est pour
ça que tous nos lieux de collecte qui
existe aujourd'hui il faut absolument
qu'il cette saturé pour réussir à
contrebalancer ce manque d'effectif donc
si vous êtes personnel infirmier si vous
êtes médecin venez nous voir il y a des
postes tout à fait intéressants chez
nous c'est notre manière d'exercer la
médecine si notre manière de prendre en
charge des patients mais qui est tout
aussi indispensable et qui peut
permettre à certaines personnes qui sont
fatigués par le travail à l'hôpital de
trouver un autre moyen d'exercer son
métier vous donnez quelques chiffres
tout à l'heure il y en a un autre qui
est important c'est 1700 dons qui sont
nécessaires chaque jour en Île-de-France
pour soigner les malades une collecte
indispensable toute l'année d'autant que
les produits sanguins ça c'est important
on le répète à chaque fois sur ce
plateau mais sont limités aussi ils ont
une durée de vie limitée et donc il faut
les renouveler tout à fait 42 jours pour
les concentrés de globules rouges 7
jours pour les plaquettes et on comprend
bien qu'on est en permanence s'affrutant
dû et encore combien qu'il faut tous les
jours tous les jours renouveler le stock
consommer la veille c'est pour ça que
nous appelons c'est très simple pour
donner son sang vous allez sur un moteur
de recherche vous mettez dans du sang
vous avez trouvé notre site vous pourrez
prendre rendez-vous vous pouvez faire un
petit questionnaire d'éligibilité pour
vérifier que dans les grandes lignes
vous pouvez donner votre et vous venez
nous voir après votre rendez-vous ça
prend une heure et en une heure vous
serez trois vies vous avez toutes les
informations sur le lien qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran et dire peut-être aux
donneurs que ils peuvent donner
plusieurs fois dans l'année c'est aussi
la régularité qui compte donner une fois
c'est bien un homme peut donner jusqu'à
6 fois il me semble son sang dans
l'année une femme 4 fois c'est ça tout à
fait exactement et les dons espacés
toutes les 8 semaines au moins et donc
une petite question de d'origine
en fait dites que la communauté afro
caribéenne c'est ça et ce qui a une
communication qui est spécifiquement
adressée à cette communauté ce qui sont
au courant justement de ces
problématiques et bien c'est tout
l'enjeu de cette semaine de
sensibilisation des soeurs que des
réussir à faire cette communication de
travail beaucoup avec des associations
nous essayons d'avoir des leaders
d'opinion dans les quartiers
intéressants pour faire en sorte de
réussir à développer cette communication
sans des communautés en question et en
tout cas nous sommes disponibles pour
travailler avec vous pour le faire et
intensifier cette action qui est un
enjeu majeur de santé publique on
précise que des collectes mobiles sont
organisés aussi dans les prochains jours
dans les Yvelines mardi au
Tremblay-sur-Mauldre à Rosny-sur-Seine
mercredi à Bonnières-sur-Seine la selle
Saint-Cloud jeudi à Chambourcy vendredi
Feucherolles et Toussus-le-Noble et ce
dimanche à septoï voilà vous avez le
programme dans les unes pour cette
semaine il y aura d'autres collègues
organisé tout au long du mois de
novembre et n'hésitez pas à vous rendre
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran pour connaître toutes ces
dates merci Stéphane Noël d'être venu en
parler en plateau je rappelle que vous
êtes le directeur de l'établissement
français
Île-de-France autre sujet de d'actualité
autre sujet de santé on en disait un mot
aussi tout à l'heure à Chatou sur cette
journée nationale de la protection
adaptée je le disais c'était organisé
par le groupe arpaville l'agence
interdépartementale de l'autonomie vino
de scène et la société Noé avec son
président qui est avec nous en plateau à
Thierry et de quoi vous donniez ce
chiffre tout à l'heure assez édifiant 5
millions de personnes qui sont
concernées par les protections adaptées
en France qui porte des protections
adaptées on disait tout à l'heure c'est
c'est un fort en jeu de santé publique
c'est d'intérêt public aussi c'est
simplement un jeu d'intérêt public qui
est pas tellement connu dans
l'importance d'organiser ces événements
pour que le public soit au courant mais
également pour essayer de faire monter
en compétences les professeurs les
professionnels du secteur du maintien
d'officier ça c'est vraiment extrêmement
important il faut savoir que il y a plus
de 5 millions de personnes parce qu'on
ne s'adresse pas uniquement aux
personnes qui souffrent d'un continent
il y a beaucoup d'autres publics qui
portent des protections on va prendre
par exemple les enfants qui souffrent
des néurésies 5% des en France qu'est-ce
qu'on leur met comme protection faut des
protections adaptées sinon il y a des
risques de harcèlement à l'école il y a
des risques etc des difficultés à avoir
des réseaux d'amis donc il y a les
personnes qui sont aussi à mobilité
réduite une personne qui se déplace
difficilement ne souffre pas
nécessairement de la continence mais a
besoin de porter des protections
maintenant la vraie question c'est quel
type de protection il y en a plus de 220
et qui est comment on peut faire
véhiculer l'information pour que les
gens ne se trompent pas de protection
tout cette journée et pourquoi est-elle
nécessaire à organiser est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il y a encore un tabou
peut-être sur la question de
l'incontinence par exemple il y a
toujours un tabou ça c'est évident il
faut remercier de nous donner la parole
sur ce sur ce sujet c'est très très bien
il y a aussi un manque de formation
évident il y a pas de formation qui
existe sur ces problèmes d'incontinence
et donc il est temps que les gens
changent il y a beaucoup beaucoup de cas
difficiles désespérés on a des problèmes
d'isolement social on a des problèmes de
perte financière quand on n'utilise pas
les bonnes protections on a des risques
de chutes qui sont beaucoup plus
importants la nuit tous ces phénomènes
font qu'il est grand temps de mettre ce
sujet sur la table et apporter les
solutions parce qu'on l'a compris on
parle d'un enjeu de santé mais qui a des
répercussions sur beaucoup de choses
dans la vie sur l'insertion vous le
disiez l'isolement aussi que peuvent
ressentir ces personnes ou par lui aussi
tout à l'heure des de cas à l'école mais
également ça plein de conséquences c'est
un véritable désespoir encore une fois
qu'on connaît pas mais effectivement les
personnes restent au sein de de enfermer
dans l'appartement dans leur maison ne
veulent parfois même plus retrouver les
familles proches à cause de ce problème
qui est un petit peu tabou et ça il faut
rendre de l'espoir et donc le seul
message qu'on avait aujourd'hui pour
cette journée nationale de la protection
adaptée c'est de leur dire qu'il existe
une protection adaptée pour tous pour
tous les cas de figure et donc c'est un
message d'espoir qu'on a voulu faire
passer on a vu quelques images de cette
rencontre à Chatou qui était les
personnes présentes il y avait une
cinquantaine d'invités c'était
essentiellement axé sur les
professionnels puisqu'on veut les faire
monter en compétences et donc on avait
une cinquantaine d'habitants en
présentiel Armelle Tilly la présidente
de l'agence inter département de
l'autonomie le groupe arpavie tous ces
gens-là étaient présents et en simultané
on a organisé deux formations en
visioconférence à destination des
travailleurs sociaux des assistantes
sociales des auxiliaires de vie et des
formations qui vont être très très
enrichissantes parce que encore une fois
ils connaissent pas beaucoup ces
éléments c'est pas sûr non et donc il
est professionnel qui manque de
formation vous le dites il faut aller de
l'avant est-ce que le tabou dont on
parlait tout à l'heure existe aussi du
côté des professionnels de santé alors
il faut savoir que ça évolue quand même
un peu par rapport à quelques années
quand j'ai démarré aujourd'hui on en
parle beaucoup plus facilement si on en
parle pas il y aura pas de solution
alors il faut tendre une perche à ces
personnes qui souffrent d'un continent
ou qui portent des protections et leur
apporter les solutions adaptées à leur
cas particulier quand on leur en parle
ils en parlent ils échanges assez
facilement donc on peut leur envoyer une
boite sauvetage pas de problème donc
formé davantage les professionnels de
santé peut-être alerté aussi les
pouvoirs publics je sais pas sur sur
cette question
nous nous soutiennent dans nos actions
Armelle Tilly était bien présente
aujourd'hui
oui il est temps il est temps maintenant
de de prendre ce sujet après le corps
oui qu'en est-il ressorti vous avez bon
espoir il y a une bonne chose qui sont
ressorti de cette journée alors cette
journée c'est pas et c'est un
aboutissement à plusieurs étapes on a
créé un label expert incontinence pour
les saintes on a créé l'opération 100 %
protection adapté sur les territoires
c'est donc un nouvel événement mais oui
il y a aucun problème on avance très
très vite mais vous le disiez donc des
modules de formation qui ont été
organisés par vous notamment votre
société si on peut dire aussi quelques
mots sur la société Noé qui est qui est
vraiment spécialisée sur sur cette
thématique je voulais quand même
remercier nos partenaires qui sont venus
de façon tout à fait bénévole
aujourd'hui si je l'organisme de
formation 2 à 3 santé sociale avec
annemortreux qui est venu faire une
présentation le groupe
Ideon texte qui est à fabuleux fabricant
de protection qui est venu aussi faire
une présentation bon Noé notre métier
c'est de nous rendre au domicile des
particuliers et d'effectuer un bilan
incontinence pour savoir exactement de
quel type de protection ils ont besoin
mais pour ça il faut aller au domicile
il faut échanger apporter les solutions
puis après le cas échéant ramener faire
le portage de protection à domicile
c'est un métier qu'on a inventé en fin
de compte et l'échange hein c'est très
important je me souviens d'avoir fait un
reportage c'était lors d'une table ronde
que vous aviez organisé aussi dans le
Sudin avec la députée Aurore berger à
l'époque pour parler justement de ce
sujet et alerter sur sur ces sujets un
site internet peut-être à donner pour
s'informer sur sur le sujet un continent
Info Service où tu avais ça dans un dans
les moteurs de recherche vous allez
obtenir beaucoup d'informations et puis
des conseils de nos experts incontinence
merci à Thierry de moi je le rappelle
président de la Société Noé
professionnelle de santé merci d'être
venu d'être venu parler en plateau de
cette journée à Chatou en cette journée
nationale de la protection adaptée sur
TV 78 nouveau numéro du PAF Patrice and
friends Patrice carmouz entouré de ses
chroniqueurs Najet sumar Virginie févé
Xavier Bossac et Nicolas dandry parle de
thème d'actualité notamment de la loi
locmi qui arrive aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée nationale avec un volet sur
la cybersécurité explication avec cet
extrait donc cette sécurité qui est en
discussion aujourd'hui l'assemblée et
dans cette voie sécurité il y a volé sur
la cybersécurité c'est ça la loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur qui a été en
première lecture au Sénat et là qui
arrive à l'Assemblée nationale et donc
il y a plusieurs dispositions qui sont
préconisées dans cette loi d'abord créer
un appel d'urgence aujourd'hui on a le
17 pour contacter la police là ça serait
le 17 cyber c'est à dire que si vous
subissez une attaque vous pouvez appeler
le 17 cyber et ça permettra de signaler
justement qu'on a été victime d'une
cyber attaque ensuite il y a une
augmentation des moyens 1500 cyber
patrouilleurs déployés 1500 personnes
supplémentaires il y aurait une école de
formation de la cyber du ministère de
l'Intérieur et des outre-mer et
sensibiliser aussi 100% des entreprises
au risque de cybercriminalité il y a
d'autres choses aussi notamment cette
disposition parce qu'aujourd'hui il faut
savoir qu'il y a seulement 3% des
entreprises qui sont assurées contre ce
risque et donc et ben le gouvernement
dans cette loi veut favoriser justement
le fait que les entreprises s'assurent
par rapport à ce risque en rentrant
obligatoire tout en rendant aussi
obligatoire le dépôt de plainte au
minimum 48 maximum 48 heures après la
cyberattaque pour être indemnisé par
rapport à ce risque donc le gouvernement
veut augmenter le nombre d'entreprises
assurées mais aussi augmenter le nombre
de plaintes qui sont déposées par
rapport à une cyberattaque et permettre
justement de lancer des enquêtes ensuite
parce que le but c'est ça c'est de
d'essayer d'arrêter ceux qui sont
derrière ces cyber attaque
émission PAF à retrouver en intégralité
sur TV 78 et sur notre site TV 78.com
allez c'est l'heure d'ouvrir notre page
sport
[Musique]
dans un instant l'invité sport Mike
bocongo mais aussi Michael et Migros qui
est avec moi et on va parler de
l'événement de la fin de semaine on en
parle déjà cette semaine c'est bien sûr
la Coupe du monde de football qui va
s'ouvrir au Qatar ce sera à dimanche on
parlait tout à l'heure de la réunion de
l'équipe de France à Clairefontaine et
le premier match justement de l'équipe
de France ce sera mardi prochain face à
l'Australie mais l'événement se prépare
déjà dans les Yvelines on le disait tout
à l'heure oui tout à fait Grégory
l'équipe de France est en pleine
préparation dans les Yvelines je vous
propose de découvrir les coulisses du
centre technique national de
Clairefontaine avec le directeur du site
Eric latronico nous l'avons suivi avec
Nicolas dandry pendant une matinée à
regarder
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au Centre national du
football de Clairefontaine je suis Eric
latronico le directeur du Centre ce site
mythique permet d'accueillir et
accueillir à travers les temps depuis
maintenant plus de 30 ans différentes
sélections nationales les différentes
équipes de France qui sont succédées
c'est pas loin de 16 à la sélection
nationale qui sont venus sur le centre
dont bien évidemment l'équipe de France
A qui prochainement jouera sa prochaine
Coupe du Monde au Qatar et maintenant on
va aller faire un petit tour sur le
centre pour pouvoir voir les coulisses
c'est voir comment l'équipe de France va
pouvoir se préparer pour cette Coupe du
Monde suivez-moi
et nous voici maintenant devant la
résidence de l'équipe de France cette
mythique résidence qu'on appelle le
château lieu de résidence de l'équipe de
France et de préparation évidemment
c'est divers événements et la prochaine
Coupe du Monde au Qatar et quand on
parle du château bien évidemment on
parle de ces marches ces fameuses
marches lieu de prestige puisque c'est
là c'est marche qui permettent
d'accueillir les joueurs pour la
première fois dans la résidence de
l'équipe de France qui vont pouvoir
découvrir ce bâtiment lorsqu'ils
arrivent sur le site
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le salon est mes Jacquet est un espace
qui permet d'accueillir les joueurs qui
est une zone de loisirs finalement donc
une zone d'échange qui est propice pour
créer le collectif où les joueurs vont
pouvoir passer du temps ensemble rigoler
discuter jouer donc vous avez un
baby-foot les joueurs aiment bien
pratiquer vous avez une table de
ping-pong également qu'on vient
installer ici et puis les joueurs aiment
particulièrement jouer aux cartes
également donc c'est un l'occasion pour
eux de se retrouver et d'échanger
ensemble espace ici les particuliers
c'est un petit bureau qui permet au
coach de pouvoir s'isoler avec un ou
deux joueurs pour pouvoir parler
tranquillement à l'abri des regards
préparer des aspects tactiques
techniques avec les joueurs à chaque
rassemblement dès lors que les joueurs
se retrouvent on va diffuser en boucle
sur les différents écrans que vous
pouvez voir
les derniers matchs de nos futurs
adversaires donc typiquement pour la
prochaine Coupe du Monde ce sera le
match de l'Australie dernier match de
l'Australie qui sera diffusé pour que
les joueurs puissent s'en imprégner et
puissent voir un petit peu comment
évolue l'adversaire
[Musique]
chaque joueur a une chambre individuelle
qui lui attribué par le coach comme vous
pouvez le voir elles sont confortables
sans rien d'ostentatoire mais l'objectif
c'est que les joueurs puissent préparer
dans les meilleures conditions avec une
attention particulière sur la literie
bien évidemment pour que les joueurs
puissent dormir le mieux possible chaque
joueur a sa propre chambre et donc est
seul dans sa chambre
[Musique]
voici dans la zone de récupération donc
c'est un lieu essentiel évidemment pour
la récupération des sportifs ce que
cette salle elle permet d'accueillir les
joueurs et de récupérer après
l'entraînement de récupérer après les
matchs pour pouvoir être performant dès
le lendemain ou l'île sur le lendemain
donc on va retrouver différentes zones
où vous avez une zone ici technique avec
des appareils de musculation de cardio
qui permettent aux joueurs de récupérer
vous avez une zone également humide avec
des bassins un bassin d'eau froide et un
bassin d'eau chaude pour favoriser la
récupération entre les entraînements et
également une zone technique plus pour
la partie soin et massages pour la part
des kiné
[Musique]
chakra semblement bien évidemment il y a
toujours un passage par la case
conférence de presse et ses conférences
de presse se déroulent ici dans cette
amphithéâtre faire en Sastre de 250
places avec en contrebas
l'estrade où on va se positionner
l'entraîneur et les joueurs avec la
presse pour pouvoir interviewer
l'ensemble des protagonistes
[Musique]
nous terminons cette visite par le
terrain qui se trouve derrière moi qui
est le terrain
pibaru terrain d'honneur de l'équipe de
France avec une tribune de 500 places
c'est là où les supporters peuvent venir
acclamer l'équipe à soutenir et puis les
journalistes également lorsque les
entraînements sont ouverts aux médias
beaucoup de joueurs depuis 1988 vous
avez quand même un grand nombre de
joueurs de haut niveau qui sont passés
ici ne serait-ce que pour citer Thierry
Henry par exemple mais vous avez
également pu récemment des joueurs comme
Kylian Mbappe comme Antoine Griezmann
comme Paul Pogba qui viennent
s'entraîner ici après cette visite nous
allons en terminer donc vous voyez
l'équipe de France va arriver
prochainement se préparer pour le Qatar
on va passer deux jours ici au Centre
national du football avant de pouvoir
s'envoler pour cette prochaine Coupe du
Monde et allez les bleus
[Musique]
bon on l'a vu les joueurs de l'équipe de
France on chouchoutés ils vont y rester
très peu avec la fontaine première
entraînement ce lundi il y aura un
deuxième entraînement devant quelques
personnes demain avant de s'envoler pour
le Qatar mercredi on rappelle le premier
match France - Australie ce sera mardi
prochain pour les débuts des Bleus dans
ce Mondial un petit pronostic nickel
victoire des Bleus allez victoire des
bleus je vais dire trois un avec un but
de Mbappé et deux buts de Giroud allez
mikeongo
pour la France deux buts de Carmen et
vous les voyez aller loin les Bleus dans
cette Coupe du Monde moi je verrais bien
aller une demi-finale allez pourquoi pas
c'est difficile à dire pour l'instant
mais on va voir de toute façon au vu des
matchs de de poules qui vont nous donner
des indicatifs importants sur l'équipe
de France mais c'est vrai qu'on a une
réelle volonté de le voir aller très
très loin c'est les champions titres
avec quelques absences de poids on
rappelle un Paul Pogba et N'golo Kanté
équipe MB on l'a pris aujourd'hui parmi
les les absences de points dans dans
cette équipe de Paris Saint-Germain
à Saint-Germain-en-Laye et je tiens à
préciser que Mike va assister à
l'entraînement de l'équipe de France
normalement demain
exclu donnée par Michael moi je me
prononce pas sur les pronostics parce
qu'en général je me trompe et ça va
plutôt dans dans le sens inverse on
passe à présent nickel aux résultats
sportif du week-end dans le département
mais même en dehors du département parce
qu'on met aussi en lumière nos yvelinois
sur les différents sports et on va
prendre le large la Route du Rhum qui
est cette course en solitaire qui a qui
a débuté course transatlantique qui va
rejoindre la Guadeloupe mauvais une
nouvelle pour Louis Burton dans la
catégorie IMOCA le skipper originaire de
Rambouillet a été victime d'un dématage
ce samedi 12 novembre dans l'après-midi
au large du Portugal il viennois était
dans le top 10 de la course lorsqu'il a
dématé aux alentours de 17h il a envoyé
justement une vidéo pour expliquer ce
qu'il s'est passé on la regarde
je comprends pas
il était prudent
voilà il reste plus que ça
dégouté c'est incroyable comment ça ça
charge
à plus tard
c'est un véritable coup dur pour Louis
Burton on l'avait déjà vu l'année
dernière ces images il avait dématé sur
la Transat Jacques Vabre 2021 et là
encore une fois il démarre avec son
bureau Vallée 3 et bien sûr il va
essayer de tout réparer pour le Vendée
Globe qui qui se produira dans deux ans
mais effectivement on l'a vu sur ces
images incompréhension totale
incompréhension totale de la part de son
équipe bon bien heureusement il y a un
autre yvelinois qui est engagé dans
cette Route du Rhum
Eric Bellion le versaillé est engagé sur
cette édition 2022 dans la catégorie
IMOCA sur son bateau comme un seul homme
Powerade by Altavia le navigateur de 46
ans et pour le moment la 22e place du
classement il vise un top 15 à la fin de
la course afin de se préparer pour le
prochain Vendée Globe du football pour
continuer une contreperformance oui une
très grosse contreperformance celle de
Versailles en National une après avoir
dominé le match les joueurs de la cité
royale se sont inclinés 1-0 sur leur
pelouse contre les derniers du
classement le Stade briochin une défaite
quelques jours après la mise à pied à
titre conservatoire de leur entraîneur
Youssef chibi avec ce résultat le FC
Versailles concerne tout de même sa
deuxième place au classement avec 19
points en congé en 12 journées prochain
match pour les Yvelinois le 25 novembre
prochain sur la pelouse du Football Club
Villefranche Beaujolais du football
toujours et le championnat de régional 2
en R2 Houilles c'est largement imposé
dans le derby face à l'équipe 2 du FC
Mantois le score est sans appel 4 à 0
l'équipe 2 de Poissy a fait match un but
partout contre le FC Conflans trap perd
sur la pelouse de Champigny sur le score
de 3 à 1 au classement oui qui est
toujours invaincu et premier du
championnat Conflans et 3e Poissy 2 est
à la sixième place et Trap est avant
dernier du classement à la 11e place
football dans un instant avec un focus
sur un poste particulier celui de de
gardien de but mais d'abord toujours les
résultats sportifs et du rugby Émilie
Boulard ne sera pas champion du monde
cette année on l'a vu la semaine
dernière mais elle sera troisième de la
Coupe du monde les vinoise titulaire
avec l'équipe de France a gagné contre
le Canada dans le pour la troisième
place le score est sans appel pour les
Françaises 36 à 0 avec déjà un score de
22 à 0 à la pause les néo-zélandaises
remportent quand elles le titre face aux
anglaises encore un grand bravo Émile
Boulard contentera évidemment d'avoir un
sur ce plateau dans les prochaines
semaines bravo à elle une 3e place dans
un mondiale c'est une énorme performance
sa première participation elle a encore
jeune Emily Boulard forcément même si on
sait que l'équipe de France avait une
réelle volonté de remporter le titre ça
fait partie du sport mais il faut les
féliciter justement pour cette troisième
place bravo encore elle pour cette
troisième place sur sur le podium donc
du rugby encore le championnat de
fédéral 2 et on parle de rugby masculin
cette fois-ci après une belle
performance la semaine dernière contre
Boulogne-Billancourt Versailles était
très attendu mais les joueurs de la cité
royale n'ont pas répondu présent ils se
sont inclinés 41 à 31 à l'extérieur face
à Boulogne-Billancourt après ce résultat
les versets restent à la huitième place
du championnat prochain match ce
dimanche 27 novembre à domicile face à
Domont un dernier du classement et c'est
contre Courbevoie j'ai dit
Boulogne-Billancourt mais c'est contre
Courbevoie qu'ils ont perdu
on parle de course à pied à présent une
petite pause environ 1000 participants
étaient au départ de la course parcourir
Montigny ce dimanche cette course
labellisée permettait aux sportif de
pouvoir atteindre une qualification pour
les championnats de France entre défi du
chrono ou course loisirs les
participants au bras vés les
températures plutôt fraîches pour être
au rendez-vous un reportage de Julien
Leroy le brouillard s'était invité pour
cette deuxième édition post covid de
parcourir Montigny organisé par le
Stadium Montigny Athletic Club ses
courses de 5 et 10 km permettaient aux
participants de s'élancer à travers le
quartier du village créé en 1994 comme
un parcours loisir cette course a depuis
été labellisée au niveau régional par la
Fédération Française d'Athlétisme les
courses à label permettent aux gens qui
font un chrono de pouvoir se qualifier
pour les championnats de France et
l'intéressant c'est que elle emprunte
des le vieux villages là qui est la
naissance de Montigny-le-Bretonneux et
puis l'avenue Nicolas Abou qui est aussi
un personnage qui a été important dans
la dans l'évolution de la ville donc
c'est un peu parcours dans l'histoire
entre la création et puis et la ville
nouvelle quoi ce parcours présenté 30
mètres de dénivelé avec peu de virages
cette ini montagne avait déjà participé
à l'édition précédente son but ce
dimanche 13 novembre battre son propre
record de 45 minutes je vais pas partir
trop vite est-ce que c'est souvent le
défaut de partir trop vite et d'être
cramé ce qui a quand même 10 km donc
essayer d'avoir une allure régulière je
vais essayer de me caler sur du 4 entre
4,25 430 on va voir comment ça va être
et si j'ai du juge accélèrerais à la fin
d'autres participants étaient venus
simplement se remettre en scène le
niveau ça sera un petit niveau moyen
niveau très moyen là je me mets objectif
aller 28 minutes une fois la ligne
d'arrivée passée sabbat ne cachait pas
sa joie d'avoir terminé neuvième
féminine la cour aux serroises avait
déjà participé à l'édition précédente
j'avais fait 46 minutes donc aujourd'hui
je suis contente 43 minutes donc 3
minutes de gagner sur l'année dernière
donc je suis très contente le parcours
était difficile avec plusieurs faux
plats montants le premier coureur des 10
km à franchi la ligne d'arrivée en 32
minutes et une seconde pour la course
des 5 km alien Mehdi a décroché la
première place avec 15 minutes et 40
secondes
environ 1000 coureurs ont bravé le froid
pour participer à cette nouvelle édition
de parcourir Montigny
[Musique]
c'est Stadium prime qui est une
plateforme digitale de recrutement pour
pour les sportifs en somme c'est un peu
le Pôle emploi pour pour les sportifs
vous nous disiez tout à l'heure les
objectifs si vous pouvez les rappeler
c'est quoi les objectifs de Stadium
prime alors tout d'abord stage en frame
le Noël est stylée
on l'a choisi ensemble mon équipe ouais
on a choisi en ce mon équipe le but de
stage emprunt justement c'est c'est
favoriser justement l'accessibilité à
tous les nouveaux talents parce que
c'est un projet voilà je le disais déjà
la dernière fois c'est un c'est en eux
vraiment pour pour la digitalisation et
la démocratisation du sport de haut
niveau que ça soit les amateurs et aussi
et aussi et aussi les professionnels
donc le but c'est c'est vraiment donner
l'opportunité au joints dans le monde
entier de pouvoir se connecter dessus
sur notre plateforme et de trouver des
opportunités de travail et donc voilà
nous on n'est pas là pour concurrencer
les agents on est là pour apporter
justement une plus-value justement à un
contexte sociétal qui a évolué justement
et donc voilà c'est à quoi cet Adium
prime va va résolu de justement les
problèmes de cette société et c'est une
idée que vous aviez longtemps en tête
peut-être qu'on vous êtes encore joueur
aujourd'hui mais au cours de votre
carrière c'est vous êtes 10 ça manque
peut-être aujourd'hui dans le monde du
sport il faudrait ce type de plateforme
quand on regarde en général les deux
secteurs d'activités voilà il y a des
sites qui sont connus qui sont reconnus
et nous justement à travers Stadium Fram
nous voulons justement redorer un petit
peu le blason du sport et donner un
outil qui va permettre justement au
corps du sport de travailler et c'est
pour cela que nous avons pensé à cela et
nous avons digitalisé justement ces
plateformes là et aujourd'hui nous
sommes vraiment ravis de l'avoir lancé
parce que ça fait déjà 7 mois on a 8000
utilisateurs dessus on a 90 clubs
français on a des clubs d'élite que ça
soit dans le football et le basketball
il faut le préciser que Stadium prime
pour l'instant on traite le basket le
foot et le rugby nous avons une réelle
volonté de traiter les autres sports
majeur bien sûr que il y a aussi un
modèle économique sur Stadium frame où
nous invitons justement les agences
sportives ou les agences intermédiaires
ou les agences événementielles ceux qui
viennent travailler justement avec nous
voilà stade c'est un partenaire pour eux
c'est une aubaine je trouve justement
pour le développement du sport donc donc
voilà une communauté finalement autour
de Stadium prime exactement exactement
tout simplement on a plus besoin
peut-être d'avoir Stadium prime
maintenant qu'avant à votre avis oui je
pense que oui parce que je le disais
encore tantôt l'évolution sociétale
c'est un projet qui s'inscrit exactement
justement dans ce contexte là
aujourd'hui c'est c'est facile de
s'inscrire sur Stadium frame on vient on
prend notre téléphone on rentre nos
informations quand on a un joueur par
exemple de je sais pas moi basket
football au rugby on a juste à rentrer
les informations qui nous concernent sur
notre palpin palmarès nom de famille
les clubs où nous avons joué
ou si nous étions sous contrat ou pas ou
par exemple s'il y a des clubs qui
veulent postuler des offres et qui
cherchent justement des nouveaux joueurs
justement ce problème là aussi donc
c'est pour cela que j'ai dit encore une
fois si toute les structures sportives
utilisaient cet agent prime je pense
honnêtement que le niveau global du
sport tel qu'on le connaît va évoluer à
une vitesse vraiment impressionnante et
ça s'adresse du coup on l'a compris à
tous les sports aussi à toutes les
divisions c'est ça aussi l'idée d'aller
au plus haut niveau aussi bien sûr avant
de devenir professionnel on est déjà
amateur c'est pour cela qu'on néglige
pas les amateurs donc c'est une
plateforme qui s'adresse aux amateurs
professionnels comme je l'ai dit on
traite pour l'instant trois sports on a
aussi les agences sportives au fur et à
mesure des mois nous allons développer
et justement les autres secteurs de
d'activités sportives justement pour
permettre au corps du sport la
communauté sportive de voilà d'avoir une
plateforme qui va permettre à tout le
monde de travailler de manière sereine
et franchement j'ai envie de fortement
les clubs encore une fois de venir
travailler avec nous parce que c'est une
aubaine c'est une aubaine pour pour
notre génération pour la jeunesse et
c'est pour les Français ou c'est
vraiment pour tous les pays ça vient
prime alors Stadium n'a pas de limite
géographique c'est un projet qui
s'inscrit les étrangers par exemple sur
la plateforme bien sûr nous avons des
étrangers des Américains nous avons des
Polonais nous avons voilà des petites de
nationalités des Africains aussi c'est
un pro c'est un projet qui est vraiment
mondial
donc c'est pour cela que je dis qu'il y
a pas de limite à Stadium problème c'est
un projet qui s'inscrit vraiment dans le
contexte sociétal et voilà et puis je
suis encore hyper heureux de l'avoir
lancé avec des amis à moi qui sont les
Marty Raphaël Lancel et Stéphane riant
que je salue au passage parce que voilà
c'est vraiment un travail de longue
haleine c'est beaucoup beaucoup
travaillé mais on est on est hyper
content de de le faire et c'est gratuit
également exactement c'est important de
le préciser c'est gratuit à 100% pour
les clubs et pour les joueurs et comme
je l'ai dit au préalable il y a un
modèle économique voilà pour les agences
sportives pour les gens qui viennent sur
ça
un business avec nous voilà il y aura un
modèle économique qui sera qui sera là
aussi pour eux mais nous on va le garder
essentiellement gratuite pour les clubs
et pour les joueurs parce que c'est pour
nous c'est très important dernière
question vous en avez déjà parlé mais le
bilan est plutôt bon ça a été lancé il y
a quelques mois il y a déjà des
utilisateurs dessus bien sûr des
utilisateurs mais au-delà de ça on a
déjà déniché des nouveaux talents on a
déjà obtenu des contrats des joueurs
aussi donc voilà c'est un projet qui va
continuer à évoluer plus on aura des
gens qui viennent dessus travailler avec
nous en plus voilà il y aura beaucoup
plus d'opportunités pour les jeunes
c'est pour cela que je dis que c'est
important justement pour les clubs de
venir utiliser cette plateforme parce
que c'est eux qui viennent justement
mettre les offres les annonces et les
joueurs après derrière ils viennent
rechercher trouver des opportunités qui
pourraient leur correspondre donc voilà
c'est vraiment un travail d'ensemble
entre les clubs et les joueurs et puis
après les agents qui peuvent aussi venir
dessus dénicher des nouveaux talents
voir comment travailler avec des clubs
aussi donc voilà votre plus grand rêve
c'est peut-être de voir un jour un
utilisateur de Stadium prime être en NBA
par exemple
forcément forcément là on dirait que on
aura réussi notre mission justement de
donner des opportunités à des jeunes de
profiter de voilà de leur talent et
profiter tout simplement quoi merci Mike
merci Mike mon Congo d'être venu en
parler en plateau vous restez avec nous
parce que on va parler encore
d'actualité sportive avec vous Michael
justement l'actualité sportive c'est
c'est mascotte il me semble qu'ils ont
été dévoilés les mascottes des Jeux
Olympiques oui elles ont été dévoilées
aujourd'hui par le comité d'organisation
à des jeux les friges sauront les
mascottes des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 comme leur
nom l'indique elles sont inspirées du
bonnet phrygien symbole de la révolution
et de la République française la
mascotte a été testée et validé par des
échantillons d'enfants de 6 à 14 ans le
kojob espère écouler 2 millions
d'exemplaires des frais jusqu'aux Jeux
olympiques de 2024 vous en pensez quoi
de ces masques c'est vrai que le bonnet
phrygien j'avais le maintenant je
comprends la forme au début comprenez
pas trop la forme mais avec les images
je comprends
j'avoue que je suis pas hyper hyper fan
mais bon pourquoi pas apparemment ça
plaît aux enfants c'est eux qui ont qui
ont décidé de la mascotte donc voilà
laissons la place aux enfants première
réaction Mike mcongo si on peut
remontrer peut-être les les mascottes
pour Mike Mokongo qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez de ces mascotte pour les Jeux
Olympiques à l'occasion d'en parler de
nombreuses nombreuses reprises sur ce
plateau je trouve que c'est c'est
nouveau c'est sympa ouais moi j'aime
bien franchement avec des grands yeux
comme ça
2 millions arrivent en vendre un billet
d'ici les Jeux olympiques de 204 et
paralympique de 2024 et on va refermer
cette page sport avec du football on l'a
commencé avec du football on la termine
avec du football le petit moment plaisir
et on parlait de coupe du monde tout à
l'heure bah il y a forcément un poste
qui va être clé pour la le futur
vainqueur de cette Coupe du Monde c'est
celui de gardien de but pour remporter
la Coupe du Monde au Qatar le futur
vainqueur va s'appuyer sur un très bon
gardien c'est un véritable sport
individuel dans la pratique collective
du football le gardien c'est un poste de
son équipe alors dans les Yvelines des
stages spécifiques sont organisés à bois
flot pendant les vacances scolaires ils
sont supervisés par Salif Soumaré qui
est un gardien en National 3 il évolue
actuellement de l'US Ivry dans le
Val-de-Marne et c'est aussi l'ancien
portier de l'AS Poissy nous avons pu
suivre ces stages regardez
[Musique]
les gardiens de buts on leur propre
stage de football depuis 2020 l'ancien
portier de Poissy Salif sous-marin
aujourd'hui entraîneur dans plusieurs
clubs les organisent sur le terrain de
Bouafles pendant les vacances scolaires
l'objectif permet aux jeunes occupant ce
poste à part de pouvoir se perfectionner
de vite progresser je passais par là
quand j'étais gardien de but au plus
haut à mon plus jeune âge on n'avait pas
cette chance là d'avoir des
entraînements de gardiens et j'ai pu le
voir sur le tard que j'avais quelques
lacunes duo fêté que j'avais pas
d'autres avant de gardien de but du coup
comme je suis passé par là j'avais pas
forcément de spécifications gardiens moi
maintenant mon mon but à moi c'est
justement de transmettre au plus jeune
gardien pour qu'ils puissent avoir les
inclinés nécessaires pour justement bah
c'est pas une mur à ce poste là
au programme de la semaine de stage
travail de la technique de gardien de
but de la prise de balle au plongeon en
passant par les sorties aériennes et le
jeu au pied 5 éducateurs proposent
différents ateliers au 25 gardiens
participants des catégories U10 à U16 le
tout sous l'oeil à Visé de salive
sous-marit qui est supervise les
entraînements c'est quoi un bon gardien
pour toi aujourd'hui quelle qualité
il doit être très fortement très très
fort mentalement et il doit surtout
maintenant maintenant avec l'évolution
du football avoir un très bon sens de
jeu et surtout bah le reste va être très
bon sur sa ligne quoi c'est vraiment un
poste à part et donc c'est pour ça ça
demande beaucoup d'exigences mentale
qu'est-ce qui me plaît j'aime bien faire
des sorties ça ça me plaît j'aime bien
être méchant parce que j'adore être
méchant j'aime bien les marques des
gants j'aime bien tout en fait tout ce
qui est gardien j'aime bien c'est bien
d'être gardien puisque bah ça sauve son
équipe parce que quand la balle elle est
là avec tes face à face avec l'attaquant
bah il y a plus que toi et du coup bah
tu peux sauver ton équipe et rester bah
si tu veux si tu arrêtes le but bah
c'est toi la sauce du match quoi
comme caissier Noa les gardiens viennent
des meilleurs clubs de la région et de
France et sont souvent des habitués des
stages j'aime bien ces stages ils sont
bien parce qu'il y a plusieurs ateliers
c'est pas tout le temps les mêmes thèmes
et bah les éducateurs ils ont pas les
mêmes méthodes d'apprendre le premier
rang que j'ai commencé à faire du stage
salive du coup qui m'a qui m'a commencé
à montrer nez je les prises de balles je
faisais que les relâcher les ballons je
plonger des fois avec les pieds je tacle
et bah au fil des années j'ai commencé à
plonger avec les mains il m'a appris des
bonnes choses il m'a appris les réflexes
il m'a appris les sortir rien parce
qu'avant je faisais que mettre les
points maintenant j'arrive à la garder
franchement je suis content que mon papa
m'a inscrit merci papa
une semaine de stage comptait 150 euros
avec une paire de gants fournis prochain
rendez-vous pendant les vacances d'hiver
de Pâques et début juillet les places
sont limitées à vin ou 25 gardiens
pour ce poste au combien important avec
ces stages donc qui est se déroulent
dans les Yvelines je parle en
connaissance de cause à un poste que
j'occupe depuis mes 6 ans maintenant
gardien de but forcément ça va être un
poste clé là pour le Mondial le futur
champion du monde sera obligé d'avoir un
très bon gardien dans les buts c'est
l'une des pierres angulaires c'est c'est
l'une des pièces de la colonne
vertébrale à chaque fois je vais vous
faire plaisir Grégory mais bouffonne en
2006 s'il n'est pas là avec l'équipe
d'Italie et l'Italie ne remporte pas la
Coupe du monde donc forcément c'est un
poste clé j'étais tout à l'heure mais
l'équipe de France à
901 presque un sport individuel à
l'intérieur du sport collectif le
gardien de but c'est là il a son sa
propre technique il a même un maillot
différent finalement par rapport au
reste de l'équipe oui c'est vrai que ça
c'est particulier après il doit il doit
défendre sur son sur son territoire et
et après il y a aussi un travail
d'équipe on défensivement ou voilà tout
le monde doit être connecté mais ouais
c'est vrai que c'est un paradoxe c'est
un peu bizarre et surtout c'est très
mental il a dit le le jeune homme dans
le dans le reportage mentalement il faut
être très très fort parce que on peut ne
rien avoir à faire pendant 90 minutes et
à la 91 minutes juste avant le coup de
sifflet final bah il faut faire la
parade pour pour aider son équipe les
jeunes nous ont donné leur gardien le
petit Noah nous a parlé d'Alban Lafont
de Anthony Lopes aussi ce qui a des
gardiens vous qui sont pour le moment
au-dessus est-ce que il y a des gardes
qui se détachent actuellement Hugo
Lloris quand même et toujours un très
très bon gardien après il y a Dona Roma
avec le PSG aussi qui est un bon gardien
qui ne fera pas la Coupe du Monde
malheureusement mais c'est un bon
gardien selon moi de naruma après il y
en a tant d'autres des gardiens de
naruma aussi donneur aussi ouais bien
sûr et puis un gardien de l'équipe de
France qui s'est blessé malheureusement
pour nous
très très bon début de saison du côté de
la 6000 ans exactement c'est c'est
dommage pour nous j'aime beaucoup aussi
Neuer aussi qui est au Bayern de Munich
qui a eu qui a coulé de de très très
belles années avec le Bayern Munich et
aussi avec l'équipe d'Allemagne qui a
été championne du monde on le rappelle
en 2014 merci messieurs pour vos
analyses sportives et avant de vous
laisser c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission on va jeter un dernier coup
d'œil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
et la météo de demain vous allez le voir
assez Mossa avec le matin dans les
Yvelines mardi 14 novembre des nuages un
peu partout et des températures de 10
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans
Versailles et à Rambouillet il fera 9
degrés l'après-midi il y aura même de la
pluie de la pluie qui est annoncée avec
des températures de 12 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans Versailles et 11
degrés à Rambouillet et ce mardi nous
fêterons les Alberts voilà c'est la fin
de ce 7 8 merci de l'avoir suivie on se
retrouve demain pour une nouvelle
édition belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]